anything everyone welcome for Meetup I'm
Patricia she's from one of the
co-organizers along with Sean in the
very back we're very pleased to have you
all here I think this might be one of
our biggest turnouts of all time all
time so very happy to see you here
especially in the summer quick show of
hands who's here for the first time with
PI data and Arbor wonderful welcome and
how many of you are connected to Midas
great wonderful extra special welcome to
the - one of our sponsors so I want to
start by acknowledging all of our
sponsors numb focused sponsors our
meetup group TD Ameritrade provides the
space for us and - provides our food a
few important points before we start
emergency exits we have an emergency
exit here please do not take the
elevators if there's an emergency we're
always looking for feedback on how to
improve our meet up so you can provide
that to us directly or this email
address here PI data annarbor at
gmail.com or to our Twitter and also
we're in a borrowed space so please be
mindful and clean up after yourself so
how we do Q&A series unless your
questions are quick hold them till the
end we'll have a discussion at the end
please freeze your question in the form
of a question keep your questions to 30
seconds or less generally just avoid
long monologues there will be time for
questions at the end and time for open
discussion and other questions one on
one with the speaker
I will read our code of conduct now high
data is dedicated to providing a
harassment for commuting experience for
everyone regardless of gender sexual
orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance body size race religion or
level of experience we do not tolerate
harassment of many participants in any
form all communication should be
appropriate for professional audience
including people of many different
backgrounds and levels of experience
sexual language and imagery is not
appropriate for any of our meetup events
be kind to others do not insult our foot
down other attendees behave
professionally remember that harassment
and sexist racist or exclusionary jokes
are not appropriate for pi data
attendees violating these rules may be
asked to leave the meetup at the sole
discretion of the Vita organizers thank
you for helping make this a welcoming
friendly event for all so we're gonna do
a quick icebreaker I'd like you to
introduce yourself to your neighbor and
share what is one thing that you're
looking forward to doing this summer at
the weather my lights turned on so
debatable
[Music]
no it was my first time
[Music]
fine please
I
Oh
any very wild and crazy plans that your
neighbor had anyone want to share well
my my thing I'm most looking forward to
is floating in the Huron River anyone
else gonna do that okay this month in
data science we like to do a little
update what's going on so this new Lala
which is a product that converts your
notebooks into web apps or dashboards
Shawn do you want to say a few words
about this earth cute fuzzy dice thank
you for that but that's about it
what does I know go check it out yeah
that sounds great
okay the next event will be on Wednesday
July 10th and we will do lightning talks
so we have I think for people who have
volunteered to give a short talk will
have a port for 10 minute toxic rocks
from public service announcement Python
2.7 will retire in six months and
essentially support for Python 2 will be
unavailable also by a lot of products
that use Python they won't allow you to
use Python 2 anymore
sorry okay so now we got some time for
any community announcement announcements
if anyone has an event that they'd like
to highlight or if you're looking for
someone to join your company or if
you're looking for a company to join if
you want to introduce yourself and share
that with the group hi my name is ben
taub don't groan I'm a recruiter but
we're looking for people across the
country but particularly in Ann Arbor
I'm looking for a really strong SSIS
developer for a permanent role in a
consulting gig and in Detroit somebody
who is strong and spark in Hadoop so if
anybody's looking for like a new gig I
think you'll recognize me just pull me
aside thanks a lot
I got people to chili
[Music]
and which are people that want to do a
so come see me you I we have an office
in Colonia
the right person
[Music]
very nice
all right to see my opportunities that's
pretty good on any other and that's to
share okay
Sean I have one in partnering with Midas
in the back there we're seeking
potentially uh mentors so you have if
you're experienced in data science
working with along with the university
to help mentor students so if you're
interested please either reach out
approach us maybe after the talk as well
we we don't know exactly what the ask is
but at least we can put your name down
to follow up afterwards okay so this
could be anything from one-on-one
mentoring to just a one-time meeting
with a group experience for lunch
there's nothing is defined you know but
if you're interested we are alright so
now I will introduce our speaker
alexandra is the tech lead for the
platform team at sigit where she strives
to build products that make the
state-of-the-art in machine learning
effortless effortless to use
additionally she was a co organizer at
the Bay Area chapter of women in machine
learning and data science so let's
welcome our speaker so machine learning
and data science are really exciting
fields to be in today but what's the
first thing you think about when you
think about machine learning and data
science odds uh what obvious re no no
you can call it out if you want what do
you think about what getting the data
okay okay that's one thing um I
generally think about building a model
but yeah getting the data building a
model these are kind of what our minds
like go to when we think about these
fields but this isn't the whole picture
there's a lot of other tasks that go
into the process of building a model and
as machine learning and data science
expand as fields some of these tasks
such as the infrastructure to support
model training emerges their own
subfields so hi I'm Alexandra
I'm as was said I am the tech lead at
the platform team at sagat's and I'm
here tonight to talk about machine
learning infrastructure
which is like I said the subfield of
machine learning that is kind of devoted
to what are the infrastructure
challenges unique to this field I've
talked to some of you tonight and it
sounds like there's people all along the
kind of like model building journey from
people who are just learning to people
who understand complex topics such as
hyper parameter optimization so I hope
that there will be a little bit of
something for everyone to learn about
machine learning infrastructure tonight
I'm going to start off with a history of
the field and kind of some of the people
dynamics that lead to machine learning
infrastructure emerging as it is today
next I'm gonna go into what is hyper
parameter optimization and how does that
introduce machine learning
infrastructure challenges and give you a
really grounded look at what several
different machine learning
infrastructure tools look like and the
technologies behind them and then lastly
I'm going to show you some examples of
successful machine learning
infrastructure projects either within
large companies or open source projects
that you could potentially use at your
company and end with some thoughts for
the future when I think about machine
learning infrastructure I like to think
about the people who are in machine
learning and data science and the people
who are in infrastructure what are what
are the challenges these people are
facing who are they what did we hire
them to do so I thought this could be a
little bit participatory who do you
think gets hired into machine learning
and data science teams data scientists
okay what were what was the one in the
back problem solvers okay
data scientist problem solvers anything
any other ideas statisticians yeah that
was my that was my first answer yeah
business liaisons okay that that's when
I didn't have up there but I was
thinking you know statisticians perhaps
people who are PhDs in a scientific
field they went through a data science
boot camp we've got a lot of those in
San Francisco but mostly you think of
people who love
building models people who are really
interested in getting their hands dirty
with data is one thing I've heard from a
lot of people and then what are we
asking these people to do so what are
things that people on data science and
machine learning teams do predict okay
make predictions white right sequel
queries okay okay yeah that's a big one
analyze data yeah yeah what clean up the
data okay yes extracting extracting
insights yeah yeah so this is when I
pulled some my co-workers about what our
customers are doing generally these kind
of emerge as trends we're asking people
to gather data build models and extract
insights and these are some of the
responsibilities that we're hiring
people for and then when we build the
mandate for the team generally success
for the team looks like ML models in
production driving business decisions
so we're hiring to kind of like recap
we're hiring people who are interested
in building models were tasking them
with building models and then we're
telling them success looks like building
models so we've kind of built this data
science team together let's kind of talk
through what the process of actually
building a model looks like so if you're
a data scientist on this team and you
want to build a model you're gonna
gather some data
you're gonna play around with the data
analyze it try to build some features do
the feature extraction step you're gonna
pick a pick an ml or data science
framework you're gonna train your model
and then you're gonna analyze results
and this is like a typical model
building workflow that a data scientist
can do in our Python in an ipython
notebook just in a normal IDE on their
laptop this is a pretty standard process
but what happens to our data scientists
when they encounter an out of memory
error this can happen for
a lot of different reasons maybe they're
datasets too big maybe they're datasets
the right size but once they build their
feature set that's too large or maybe
the model just grew to an intractable
size regardless of why the situation
this now puts our data scientists in is
that they can't train their model on
their laptop anymore they want to build
a model but now all of a sudden the tool
that they're generally given their local
workstation is not sufficient so their
workflows got to change a little bit now
all the sudden we add these extra steps
you gather your data you extract your
features you pick your ml framework but
then you have to go and spin up an AWS
ec2 instance or you know like and then
once you spin out the instance you have
to set up the machines then you have to
remotely launch the training job on this
instance and then and only then can you
analyze your results but you know this
new workflow doesn't really look like
what we hired the data scientist to do
these tasks here highlighted in blue
look like kind of the responsibilities
that we hire the data scientists for but
these extra ones are better categorized
as infrastructure work the point here is
that now the data scientist is in a
situation of being asked to do work
that's pretty different from the
responsibilities that were laid out when
the team was formed the responsibilities
that were laid out when they were hired
and you know okay maybe it's fair to say
you've got one data scientist and
they're trying to build models using one
AWS ec2 machine is it really that much
of a big deal if you're already
proficient in building models it may
only take you a day to learn how to do
this and actually requiring a data
scientist to know a little bit of
infrastructure isn't actually going to
be detrimental to your data science team
it may be appropriate the issue comes
when the infrastructure
the issue comes when we ask our data
scientists to not only be experts in
data science but we also ask for them to
be experts in infrastructure as well
because infrastructure is its own
separate specialty in computer science
and these are just examples of some of
the reasons why our infrastructure might
scale maybe you have like we're talking
about large data sets features models
that lead to out of memory errors but
maybe you just have a large team of data
scientists and every single one of them
wants to be able to close their laptop
when they go home and still be able to
monitor their training progress maybe
you need access to specialized hardware
like GPUs or something like that in all
of these cases the infrastructure is
scaling to be very large and we're left
asking the question is it fair to ask
the data scientists to manage all this
infrastructure but if the data scientist
isn't handling their infrastructure who
is responsible for spinning up and
managing the data scientists
infrastructure well we have a guess of
who we could ask it's in the name you
know we could ask the infrastructure
team perhaps the infrastructure team is
able to help out the data science team
which is why I want to go back to the
people who form these teams data science
and like in large corporations data
science teams are relatively new as they
kind of exist today but infrastructure
teams are a little bit more established
infrastructure teams have a little bit
of a different way that they work so we
talk through who we have on these
infrastructure teams and what their
responsibilities are for these already
established teams we're seeing that
we're hiring people like systems experts
and back-end engineers and what we're
asking them to do is we're asking them
to be responsible for reliability
scalability and performance now this
seems honestly like a pretty good match
these seem based on what we're seeing
here they seem like people who our data
scientists could ask for help from but
here's where the tricky part comes in
the infrastructure team having already
been around for a while at the company
has their hands full with other
responsibilities in my work as an
infrastructure engineer at cig apt we're
responsible for fulfilling customer
service level agreements and keeping our
API and website up and running to a
certain level of uptime specification
and infrastructure engineers at other
companies may be organized around
similar objectives the point is the data
science team is still feeling this pain
and the infrastructure team may have the
expertise but they've already got their
hands full with a lot of other things
they've got a list of pre-existing
objectives and they're not just sitting
around waiting for extra work so it's in
this environment that machine learning
infrastructure emerges as its own
subfield the work that we're asking for
the work that we're asking out of
machine learning infrastructure is
nominally some of the same kind of
infrastructure expertise and tooling
that we've had before but we're asking
to apply it in a pretty different way
helping data scientists build tools is
pretty different from keeping an API up
and running it requires different
workloads it sometimes requires
different technologies and there's a lot
of exciting new challenges so machine
learning infrastructure has emerged as
this kind of confluence of data science
and machine learning users and workloads
plus infrastructure and DevOps tools and
expertise and this is a field that I am
really excited about because I think
there's a lot of really cool challenges
here
so I've kind of talked about who are the
people who are on these data science and
machine learning teams and who are the
people on these infrastructure teams and
why can't they just all help each other
out I've kind of given a little bit of
context as to why the machine learning
infrastructure field has arisen today
now what I want to give you is a
grounded look at some different machine
learning infrastructure tools and some
of the technologies that were used to
build these tools so I'm going to
introduce hyper parameter optimization
and the infrastructure challenges and
then show you what it looks like when a
data science team builds their own tools
and then show you what it looks like
when an infrastructure team overhauls
some of those tools quick show of hands
how many of you have heard of hyper
parameter optimization before okay cool
every model has hyper parameters hyper
parameters are the configurable values
that you set on your model before you
begin to train with any data different
settings of hyper parameters have a very
large impact on the performance of your
model and hyper parameter optimization
abbreviated HBO because it is very
difficult to say a lot is the search for
the best set of hyper parameters it's
the search for the set of hyper
parameters that produces the best
performance for your model these are
some example hyper parameters if you've
ever built a random forest model you may
have been left wondering how do I set
the values for the number of trees in a
forest how do I set the values for the
maximum depth per tree and you can use
Hyper parameter optimization to help you
figure out which values for a number of
trees in a forest or maximum depth per
tree can help you maximize the accuracy
of your random forest model and this is
true of almost any model out there you
can use hyper parameter optimization to
help you figure out which configuration
values will produce the best performance
for your model
Hyper parameter optimization is a great
challenge for machine learning
infrastructure because it essentially
trades off compute power for model
performance hyper parameter optimization
can help get you to the upper echelons
of model performance but it may require
in kind of the upper echelons of model
compute as well if you're used to
training your model one time and your
model has ten high per parameters you
may need to train your model a hundred
times to find the best set of hyper
parameters for your model and that's
with some of the more sophisticated
methods if your model takes an hour to
Train this means that you're going to be
left waiting about four days to receive
your results which and kind of like work
time means that it's gonna take you all
week to kind of set up this experiment
wait for results and analyze it and when
something's sitting around for an entire
week running in the background that can
be kind of distracting so we're left
with this situation where we want to get
the maximum performance out of our model
we want to use hyper parameter
optimization to get the maximum
performance out of our model we're
running into a situation where hyper
parameter optimization wants to train
our model a hundred times and that's
taking a whole week so we can paralyze
we can paralyze the model training
across six different machines to reduce
the wall clock time that means instead
of waiting around for results for a week
we're only waiting around for results on
the order of a day and I don't know
about you guys but for me that would be
a lot less distracting a lot easier to
kind of like on a human level manage
this process going back to my earlier
point though you see that we want to
paralyze hyper parameter optimization to
six machines who is responsible for
spinning up and managing these six
machines is it fair to ask the data
scientist
to spin up and manage those six machines
so your mileage may vary and
I'm gonna show you what it looks like
when data scientists build tools and
when infrastructure engineers build
tools to help kind of manage the process
of starting hyper parameter optimization
jobs these both have kind of like a
common theme where the problem they're
trying to solve is getting code and
dependencies onto a remote machine onto
a remote machine starting jobs and then
monitoring the progress data scientists
build tools that they trust in 2017
every new machine learning project at
Sagat was producing a new machine
learning tool that was handcrafted for
that data scientists or person doing the
data science project and that particular
project so each kind of like folder in
our examples repository would have a
different set of code for spinning up
machines and doing that process I talked
about getting code onto the remote
machines launching the job and viewing
the progress what this meant was that
each machine learning project was taking
time out of that project to write this
specialty code in an area of computer
science that wasn't related to the goal
of the project and this code was being
kind of repeated by every person
additionally what you'll see is that the
tools that ended up being produced we're
kind of an afterthought the tools was
kind of the tools were kind of the
easiest thing that could be built to get
the job done so what do these tools look
like
to solve the first problem of getting
code and dependencies from your local
laptop to the 6 remote instances you
would SCP everything everywhere you'd
use SCP to send every single file from
your workstation to every single remote
machine that met if you close your
laptop at any point during this process
you could lose all of your progress
because these tools didn't do a great
job of keeping track of the progress for
launching jobs these tools generally use
SSH to run remote to run commands on
remote instances you can use SSH to both
login to an instance and run a command
yourself but you can also use it to
automatically send a command to a remote
machine to run finally for viewing
progress and debugging jobs well sig up
provides an API for hyper parameter
optimization so all of the tools would
use the sig UPS API to help track
metadata about the job and then they
would also run remote jobs on remote
instances in T mocks windows so what's
happening is that each remote instance
is training the model over and over and
over again on different sets of hyper
parameters so when you use T max to run
a process on a remote instance if that
job fails you can SSH on to this
instance you can open up the team X
window and you can see a record of all
the logs and the stack trace from the
failed process so it was better than
having nothing kind of rudimentary
debugging tools
as I said data scientists built tools
that they trusted when you are kind of
wearing the data science hat on your
project you wanted to build something as
quickly as possible but what this kind
of led to in retrospect is people built
tools that they really understood people
built tools that they had full control
over when you built a machine learning
infrastructure tool for your project you
understood exactly what was going on you
had full kind of autonomy to do whatever
you wanted you didn't have to ask anyone
else to implement a new feature for you
you didn't have to ask anyone else to
debug something for you you could figure
it all out on your own but while these
tools were very usable by the individual
data scientists who wrote them some of
the problems lay on kind of the
infrastructure and team fundamentals
side it was difficult to share tools
between different people so every
project would end up needing to spend
those extra couple of days to build a
new tool again and this seems pretty
simple but you couldn't close your
laptop while some of this stuff was
running and being able to being able to
have a job run asynchronously on
different machines actually becomes a
big deal when there's a lot of different
things you're doing additionally this
kind of process of needing to
communicate with each machine
individually to send over code or to
start jobs it worked fine for one or two
machines but this doesn't scale well to
a hundred machines the point is that the
data science tool was customized for
that person but it still had some some
features that were maybe not so great on
the infrastructure side so the next
thing we looked at was asking the
infrastructure engineers to overhaul
these data science tools which is where
I want to leave you with this caveat
I thought that this quote did a great
job of explaining the kind of caveats
behind just across the board introducing
shared services creating shared services
also creates dependencies and can
impinge on autonomy these data
scientists were building tools that let
them have a large degree of autonomy by
having the infrastructure team come in
and build a shared tool then we're going
to lose a little bit of that autonomy so
that's just something to think about
if you're considering maybe introducing
shared tools or building shared tools
for your organization because I'm going
to talk about how that played out a
little bit when I get to the pros and
cons section but I always like to bring
it back to kind of like who are the
users who are the people who are going
to be using these tools so I got to be
the tech lead for the infrastructure
engineer overhaul in 2018 we started the
project SigEp orchestrate which had
nominally the same kind of process goals
as the previous data science tools we
wanted to be able to quickly spin up and
manage hyper parameter optimization jobs
because well if you can't tell already
hyper parameter optimization is a big
focus that's ago so the infrastructure
so the question was we had
infrastructure people busy did we get
new infrastructure people so I think
this was a little bit of a function of
the team was growing so we had a couple
of new people on the team but then also
we decided to step back and say hey this
seems to be a pretty big need in our
organization we're going to carve out
dedicated time to inform like it's a
separate sub team to be dedicated to
this effort and so it wasn't part of the
like standard infrastructure roadmap it
was definitely its own separate effort
that existed independently but that's a
good question
because as I'll talk about in the kind
of future notes section I would
definitely recommend building these
things as their own dedicated efforts
because the infrastructure work is is
different enough so the infrastructure
engineers myself included got to use
kind of the latest and greatest in
infrastructure technologies to try to
solve some of these issues if you're not
familiar with containerization you can
think of a of a container as kind of a
recipe for kind of installing and
managing your development environment so
it includes your dependencies and your
code and you'll often hear the term
docker come up because docker is the
most popular containerization technology
available today although it is not the
only one so the benefit of using
containerization is that you package up
all your code and all your dependencies
to train your model once on your local
laptop you send this one time to a
container registry and I'm using the
term container and image interchangeably
and then each each machine in the cloud
will download the container or the image
from the registry itself what this means
is that the kind of interacting with
each machine individually is all
happening behind the scenes
no more needing to leave your laptop
open for any more than just building
your container and pushing it to a
registry
to solve the problem of launching jobs
we used kubernetes specifically because
we run on AWS
we used AWS is eks which is their
managed kubernetes service kubernetes
provides kind of a way of turning your
machines into a cluster and then it also
provides a nice set of api's and
abstraction layers for things like
launching jobs specifically kubernetes
operates on the promise of container
orchestration so it's very well-suited
to launching jobs that are based on
containers and since we had committed
set containers and kind of like the last
step it was a natural choice to want to
use kubernetes because we had used
docker in kubernetes in this tool it was
easier to build debugging and monitoring
tools darker and kubernetes have these
kind of rich communities behind them and
so they've got a lot of great
abstractions and it's easy to build
really powerful stuff on top of them so
we packaged up our tool is a
command-line interface we built
abstraction layers on top of docker and
kubernetes to allow you to view status
at a glance in the command line and to
view your logs
but this tool was not without its
problems it had a great amount of
promise but it didn't do a perfect job
of connecting with the people who were
supposed to use it yes it's all these
problems of kind of reliability
scalability and performance it provided
what were in theory great debugging
tools it was highly scalable it was easy
to install but you took away a little
bit of that autonomy and this tool took
away a little bit of that freedom that
the data scientists were used to having
as I heard from someone who used it they
said you know I'm actually not that
comfortable spinning up infrastructure
but when I build my own tool I know
exactly what's going on and so I trust
that tool when you introduce this
abstraction layer on top of docker and
kubernetes well it's difficult for me to
understand what's going on and it's
difficult for me to trust that I'm not
making a mistake that's going to cost
the company thousands of dollars
additionally we had an external
dependency not only was it more
difficult for the data scientists to
trust the tool but they would have to go
to another team if they wanted to solve
bugs or if they wanted new features
built so it was a little bit it was more
difficult to use than had been
anticipated and you kind of had these
these things that play like trust and
how much do your users understand
infrastructure and how much do they want
to enter understand about infrastructure
data scientists built tools they trusted
infrastructure engineers built tools
around infrastructure principles so how
can we kind of combine these two
different views and produce great
machine learning infrastructure tools
going forwards in my opinion the most
critical thing to producing great
machine learning infrastructure tools is
going to be a tight feedback loop with
your user it's going to be very
important for these teams to develop
user empathy and you can only do that by
talking to your user again and again and
again as an infrastructure engineer it
was easy for me to get lost in the
problem and to get lost in the idea of
I'm building a technical tool for
technical people I understand what I'm
comfortable with
therefore I can build this tool to what
I'm comfortable with
it had worked for me before but when it
comes to machine learning infrastructure
tools your user set is pretty different
data science and infrastructure as I
said are two different specialties
within computer science and within the
technology industry at large they have
different people that are hired for each
role different responsibilities and
different objectives and it helps to
treat them differently when you're going
to build the tool and so it's important
to talk to your users again and again
and have them dog food these tools which
means having users kind of internal to
your team use the tools as you're
developing this is my hypothesis the
tight user feedback loop is my
hypothesis as to why some of the most
successful machine learning
infrastructure projects today are coming
out of teams at large companies I'm
hypothesizing that it's because the
machine learning infrastructure teams
have ready and easy access to the data
science users because they're building
products for an internal team although
some of these have plans to be open
sourced and some of them may have been
open sourced already I know that
Google's Borg project which is a little
bit more general was turned into
kubernetes
but I do think that there will be some
startups emerging startups who are
dedicated to machine learning
infrastructure can get this type
feedback loop by working very closely
with their customers and I'm really
excited to see what's on the horizon in
the next 5-10 years when it comes to
machine learning infrastructure I also
want to give some love to the open
source machine learning infrastructure
projects out there many of these are
based on kubernetes
clusters as a back-end but these are all
available for you to kind of use within
your organization right now I have
written and spoken on this topic before
if you're interested in learning more
about the cig up orchestrate tool me and
my colleague Michael McCourt have
written a paper there's a blog post on
machine learning infrastructure and I
gave a similar talk for ML conf NYC this
year so what I'd like you to kind of
take away is a little bit about the
dynamics but behind how these in
finishing learning infrastructure tools
are built data scientists build tools
they trust infrastructure engineers
build tools that are robust how we can
kind of move towards a future where
we're building robust tools that are
trusted is by having a tight user
feedback loop and by talking very
frequently to the people who will be
using these tools last thing if you are
interested in talking more and maybe in
letting me come by your office and
seeing how you work I'm gonna be around
an arbor until 5:00 p.m. tomorrow and I
would love to kind of see you in your
environment and see what's going on so
if you're in this area and want to talk
further please reach out and thank you
so much for having me pie data and Arbor
and I can now take a few questions
yes so at Sega so the question was do I
have any thoughts on ml4 Kubb flow and
am i using them in my company so at Sig
apt we build an API for hyper parameter
optimization so generally when we do
data science projects it's to either
write a blog post to showcase the power
of hyper parameter optimization or to
help our customers who are attempting to
build models and show them the value of
hyper parameter optimization so we use
orchestrate internally or the home built
tools that the data scientists have done
we don't have any plans to adopt those
larger tools because we don't have a
data science pipeline to support it yes
so the question was have you looked into
agile type project management tools to
help with that tight user feedback loop
and you know what I would say for this
is we are a very small startup we're
about 25 peoples we have not yet
introduced agile but that sound
something like that sort of process
where you've got a full dedicated team
effort that has maybe its own product
manager and its own engineers to build
machine learning infrastructure tools is
something like what I would recommend so
agile would be a great thing to look
into for machine learning infrastructure
tools specifically what the benefits
that would provide is regularly talking
to users and a little bit more structure
around scoping out these projects yes
any engineer in the areas
looking yeah I am from the Bay Area so
your question was how would I define the
job scope of a machine learning engineer
so what I would say is that job scope
varies wildly from company to company
and so I would read that company out if
you're interested in a particular
company you're interested in what does
it mean to be an a machine learning
engineer that company you're gonna need
to read that company's Job Description
to figure out what it is historically
people with the title machine learning
engineer have taken on a little bit more
of this infrastructure responsibility
than people with the title data
scientist but what I've seeing is that
that's sort of breaking out and they're
becoming their own team so yeah you're
gonna have to check on a company by
company basis and that's just because
the industry so the question was did you
consider having an infrastructure
engineer sit on the data science team or
having a data scientist sit on the
infrastructure team and see what you
could produce that is something I would
definitely recommend for other people
who want to build tools like this again
we're small and we're pretty resource
constrained so that wasn't necessarily a
resource that we could that we could
devote at the time yes
u.s. the users get any say of how much
like paralyzation what kind of machine
will be spun up because they will get to
build benefits I have yes I want the
results fast but I can want a lot of
procedure in parallel but they don't
forget about to build so is there a way
for users of Sega to kind of see where
my resource build would be yeah so the
question was using a machine learning
infrastructure tool like stick up
orchestrate does the user have control
over which machines are being spun up
and how many machines are being spun up
and from that does the user have any
control over how much their experiment
is going to cost so the answer is yes
the user has total control over how much
their experiment is going to cost all of
the model training is done within the
users environment and they specify the
type of machine and the number of
machine production when you say
production level does that mean
production iliza models and serving
results so our product doesn't currently
we're focused on helping people what the
question was do these infrastructure
tools carry on to the production ization
of machine learning models which is
generally scoped to mean you have a
machine learning model and it's may be
accessible via an API and someone
outside of that team can hit it and ask
for results
the answer is our tool doesn't some
tools do focus on that that is a we
focus on the problem of helping people
launch hyper parameter optimization jobs
but the process of production iliza
models is a big part of the industry and
that's what some tools are focused on
sharing like for the notebooks the
common code sharing how do you work a
straight
and so that it can cheer for different
tasks that you don't have to rewrite
because that was one of the paint words
I heard from the data scientists that
they had to read everybody has to write
a similar code and have to and then
waste time on not sure yeah so the
question was how do you solve the
problem of sharing code maybe across
different ipython notebooks and that I
would say is a longer answer I would I
don't have much expertise in that area
but I'd love to hear a little bit more
maybe offline about your particular
problems that you're facing
sorry can you repeat that question
yes so the question was about what's the
method of hyper parameter optimization
so the answer is there's many different
methods for performing hyper parameter
optimization when you're just trying out
different configurations of hyper
parameters on your own
that's called manual optimization when
you're enumerate n't possible values of
say for different parameters on a sort
of grid that's called grid search at sig
opt use a technique called Bayesian
optimization that underlies our hyper
parameter optimization and Bayesian
optimization is a very popular technique
within hyper parameter optimization
today it allows you to see better
results faster than manual tuning or
than great and random search bayesian
optimization please don't ask me to
spell it still have anxiety from the
fourth grade spelling bee okay so the
question was how is this machine
learning infrastructure different from
auto ml platforms like Amazon Sage Maker
so that's a great question a lot of
these machine learning infrastructure
tools look different on the surface but
when you kind of peek in you see that
while there's a lot of tasks in machine
learning you can almost like make these
check boxes as to what are all the tasks
and how many of them does each tool
handle so a tool like say got
orchestrate is going to handle a very
low number of those tasks it's going to
only see check marks in the boxes of
spinning up machines launching jobs and
monitoring hyper parameter optimization
jobs but a tool like AWS sage maker is
going to have check boxes in a lot for a
lot more features eight I understand the
AWS sage maker helps you with a much
larger part of the kind of model
building and production Allah zation
pipeline where this comes into play is
that different teams have different
requirements for things like
what Amazon is allowed to see you know
if you're Walmart and you can't use AWS
sage maker but also if you're a team
that maybe can't let their data leave
their machines then you're not going to
want to then you're going to want to use
a tool that handles less of the process
for you and so it's really all about
like what's the feature set and then for
your team the question is how much of
this feature set are you comfortable
letting another company handle for you
we're on kind of the very lightweight
side Atos stage makers on the very
heavyweight side and there are use cases
for both want to see some slides one
last question is for either current
customers or potential customers what
should they be looking forward to and
then your futuristic off weather product
line I was sure yeah so this is a good
point cuz I know a lot of you are coming
from University of Michigan and the
Midas group but Sega is free for
academic users so if you are a current
student and you are interested in using
cig opt sign up online I don't know what
the current process is but email the
email address that you're given and you
can get free access if you're an
academic user for use in your projects
and then some of the interesting things
to look forward to are more tools for
being able to kind of monitor your
progress as you're training your machine
learning job so if you're doing this
heavy-duty model training like I'm
talking about you're gonna have kind of
like more insights into what your models
doing while you're training it improved
UI UX features like that we've also had
a lot of great stuff come out recently
around the dashboard grouping and team
collaboration tools that the platform
team has been working very hard on you
would learn a lot but we also try to
remember that empathy really is a key
part of being sore
Athena signs feels right and so with
that lets thank alexander for another
[Applause]
you